nein
oh mein gott mir wurde mal wieder ein
video empfohlen trotz muss was auch
immer das ist anders muss zwanghaft
seinen unterleib reiben
ja hilf mir halt ich muss trotzdem erst
mal kurz nachschauen was frau tourismus
ist froh turismo sexuelle die aktion bei
der sich sexuelle lustempfinden nur
durch reiben der genitalien am
bekleideten partner erleben lässt
ich würde sagen wir schauen uns das mal
an da läuft gerade copyright musik
deswegen hört ihr gerade
hintergrundmusik von mir darüber gelegt
das hier ist anscheinend der typ nahm
das hat gut getan
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
genauso also das hier ist entscheiden
dieser menschen namens anders allein
dass der typ auch einfach anders heißt
und erst jetzt gerade in den wald
gelaufen hat sich an diesem baum hier
gerieben
die hilf mir redaktion die übertrifft
sich wirklich jedes mal selbst ist eine
andere frau das ist nicht dein ernst
nein
anders du bist wirklich anders besteuert
jetzt läuft er wieder zu irgendeinem
baum hin und reibt sich an ihm die
anderen leute denken sich auch schon so
was geht da ab
der anlass der bekommt gar nicht klar
der
nein
ich dachte er setzt sich auf die bank
stattdessen wright der sich da wieder
dran anders scheint unter einer extremen
form von tourismus zu bauen
grundsätzlich versteht man unter
futurismus das reiben dass unter leute
an menschen oder gegenständen der guard
zwischen harmlosen reiben und sexueller
belästigung ist allerdings sehr schmal
und anders muss unbedingt aufpassen
sonst kann er sich ganz schnell in
schwierigkeiten bringen das ist
hier abgestürzt oder was erstmal so die
grobe einleitung der heutigen folge
es wurde gruppe erklärt wer anders ist
und zwar hat er froh tourismus dh er
macht gern so was in seiner freizeit und
jetzt gehts dann scheint los mit der
richtigen folge
das heißt ja ich glaube schlimmer kann
es gar nicht mehr werden anders lebt zu
hause bei seiner mutter dorothea seit
dem tod seines vaters haben die beiden
ein ganz spezielles verhältnis von
anders heimlich im drang
er kommt nach hause das erste was er
macht es sich einem stuhl reiben alltag
wurde jetzt gar noch sexuell erregt als
er seine mutter da angefasst hat also
klar leute ich sag das ja immer bei
reactions es geht überhaupt nicht gegen
die leute hier man merkt dass alles nur
geschauspielert ist es sind schauspieler
das sind einfach nur geschaut
das ist einfach schauspieler ich habe
den ganzen vormittag super müssen
versuchen
der an das ist 30 oder sowie die
einrichtung von ihrer klasse hier noch
so kipping und hier dann alles in einem
komplett anderen ton das erste mal das
anders was gesagt hat in dieser folge
hausaufgaben
die noch zur schule ist das eigentlich
ein tolles kunstwerk und den ganzen tag
das sieht ja das sieht nach einer sehr
ungesunden mutter sohn beziehung auch
alle dorotheas verhalten könnte der
grund für anders außergewöhnliche
neigung sagt wirklich denn sie nötigt
ihn zu intensiven körperlichen kontakt
nach nur für seine entwicklung ist danke
danke für deine therapeutischen hinweise
waren eure eltern früher so ich weiß es
gab früher so eltern die also die
kinderzimmer so zurecht gestutzt haben
dann so die haare richtig gemacht hat
und bleibt zum glück waren meine hält
habe nicht so dementsprechend sah ich
auch herzlich aus nein
allein dass die mutter auf ihre wange
zeigt und dann küssen sie sich auf den
mund jäger da läuft einiges schief in
der mutter sohn beziehung durch ihre
fixierung auf anders versucht sie den
verlust ihres mannes zu kompensieren und
dabei bemerkte roth ja noch nicht mal
wie unwohl sich anders fühlt ich frage
also die wie therapeuten die fresse du
laden an das steht ständig unter druck
seinem fatalen zwang nachgehen zu machen
nein anders tut mich das ist nicht
erlernt
besonders
anders so ein vorbild an das ist völlig
überfordert mit seinem zwang sich zu
reiben sein bester freund nils weiß
davon nichts mit einem kumpel klar wir
müssen die mädchen wir sollen das macht
mich ein bisschen entspannter wirst
immer so vielleicht ein late 1 live
was hältst du von der idee in richtung
jugendzentrum laufen und mädchen da sind
doch immer ein paar geile weiber die
wehren können das ist bei uns nicht
anders auch mal dran reiben
nein was machst du da viel zeit anders
dabei denkt er sichert eine schaukel hat
gerieben hat herr renz martin gelaufen
bekommen spaß service entspannt sondern
ist eine neigung wie oft kommt einer
dieser charaktere beutin also wer anders
hat seinem kumpel erklärt dass er
dagegen gelaufen sei ja so laufe ich
auch mal wenn ich irgendwo gegen laufe
und jetzt kommt mal wieder unsere
therapeuten ist eine neigung zu beichten
kommt für anders noch nicht in frage das
wäre der erste schritt in die richtige
richtung
danke zwei stunden später haben das ist
jetzt zurück bei seiner mama die halter
essen lasst es schmecken sexy was denn
heute mit mir zum jugendzentrum alter
habt ihr die hand gerade gesehen holte
mit munition jugend der anders tut mir
wirklich ein bisschen leid basics was
hältst du davon wenn ich uns bei der
tanzschule anmelder
oh mein gott jetzt geht der anlass mit
seiner mutter eine tanzschule oder das
audit hand schule und irgendwann war es
dann so dass sich irgendwie hälfte der
stufe der angemeldet hat und ich gehörte
zu der anderen hälfte und ich kann immer
noch nicht richtig tanzen
es muss immer öfter seinem zwang sich zu
reiben nachkommen der kleinste weit
reicht dem 17 jährigen schon als
auslöser also man muss sagen
reifen sind bei ihm nicht gegenstände
sondern wirklich dann auch frauen anders
zwang wird immer mehr zu einem ventil
für jeglichen stress er braucht dringend
therapeutische hilfe um sein verhalten
zu verstehen und bewusst steuern zu
können danke hätte ich jetzt noch nicht
sagen können dass der andere hilfe
braucht ihr wisst ich bin noch reichwald
wissen ob anders sah es anders
ja ich bin seine freundin
no way
anders hat eine freundin das setze ich
war
nein oh mein gott
ich sagte er ist sie entdecken denn
jetzt aber der geht dem immer wieder aus
dem weg seit gestern hat mama wird sonst
kurz allein lassen
ich möchte nicht dass du dir hast gehst
hast du verstanden was wichtig für
nehmen wir mal ich mach das macht ja
später noch am anfang
nicht dass sie ihr noch anfangen herum
zu pimpen boeing goss die lauber nimmt
den anders
sie setzen sich aufs bett wo gott ist
das kritisch
seit gestern nachmittag
allerdings
oh mein gott nein
was macht er anders jetzt
[Musik]
du gehst da war ganz schön ran
ich glaube es am besten wenn du jetzt
gehst
ich habe da noch ein haufen arbeitete
das war es übrigens dass das ende der
anders schickt seine seit gestern
vorhandene freundin weg weil er noch
einen haufen arbeit zu erledigen hat an
der stelle würde ich einfach nur sagen
[Musik]